Salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésors, on est de retour
au canal du Rhône
Vous reconnaissez sûrement la passerelle ?
Il y avait vraiment plein de choses. C'est
un endroit qui n'a jamais été fait.
Et comme la dernière fois,
on est en compagnie de ESM
On espère faire de belles trouvailles.
Il y avait un fusil ici la dernière fois,
il y en a sûrement d'autres.
Et surtout, qu'est ce que Quentin tu veux
trouver ?
Un coffre fort ici
Un coffre fort, c'est la mission du jour
Franchement ça se fait, c'est un coin de délinquants c'est faisable.
Et bien sûr, on est en compagnie
de de Rasta qui est à l'ombre
Là, en face, c'est bien.
Attention de ne pas tomber
Un fusil directement, ça nous mettrait en forme
Ouais
Alors ?
L'aimant est rempli
Il en reste
On n'a rien d'incroyable.
A part une pédale de vélo.
Ouais, un petit tournevis.
Il y avait pas mal d'outils là aussi.
On a un poids intéressant
Il y a une corde.
Un câble en acier plutôt, vieilleries
Oh, jolie
Ah oui, pots catalytiques ?
Non, c'est un scooter je pense
Moi aussi, j'ai quelque chose
Ca en fait de la connerie !
Je pense que ça ne va pas
arrêter aujourd'hui.
Encore
Il y a du poids.
C'est un moteur !
J'ai un moteur de scooter déjà.
Et une sacrée barre.
Moteur de mobylette.
Un caniche ?
Ca ressemble un peu à des cheveux, c'est dégueulasse.
Une perruque ?
On dirait une perruque avec un masque
Une mauvaise blague d'halloween
Les masques qui font peur de clown,
c'est possible.
Pourquoi dans le canal ?
Pour faire peur aux pêcheurs à l'aimant
Ou en braquage
Il y a un film comme ça ou ils sont déguisés en clowns ?
Peut être qu'ils avaient le fusil aussi. Ils ont tout jeté en même temps.
Du coup, c'était une sorte de pot.
Ça, c'est quoi ? C'est un bout de vélo.
Le pédalier.
Des chaussettes, et une chicha !
La petite chicha qui fait plaisir.
Alors là regardez, un vieux fer à repasser.
Pas le modèle en fonte quand même,
mais ça reste ancien.
Beau vélo.
Qu'est-ce que tu nous sors ?
Mais alors, qu'est ce que c'est que ça ?
Une chaise.
Il y a vraiment n'importe quoi
ici, c'est terrible.
Belle dépollution en tout cas, ça fait plaisir.
Je suis content de ma chaise.
Regardez, un cadre de mobylette.
Bien joué.
C'est quoi ça ? Un Peugeot 103 ? - Ouais
On dirait
On sait qu'il y a beaucoup d'amateurs qui nous regardent
dans les abonnés et qui aimeraient avoir des cadres comme ça
mais ils sont vraiment abîmés.
Désolé pour vous.
On est sur un spot de voleurs
de mobylettes des années 70 surement
Un garde boue là bas.
Et ici.
Je viens de trouver deux monnaies
Oh joli, du franc.
Une de 1978
Une pièce de 2 francs
Commémorative celle là
Et 0,02€,
c'est bon signe parce que ce n'est pas ici
qu'on fait forcément des vœux.
C'est un peu bizarre comme endroit
C'est bon signe des pièces
Il était tout au fond celui là
et il y a du poids
C'est encore un vélo
Une grosse barre aussi
Et encore un caleçon.
Comme on disait avec Quentin tout à l'heure
Objectif de 300 kilos, à 5 on devrait les faire là.
On y croit.
Un couteau !
On ne l'avait pas vu celui là
Il est beau, un manche en bois,
pas très vieux
Pour ça qu'il faut bien vérifier son aimant
Colombia
Si vous connaissez
les couteaux Colombia
L'entreprise sonne un peu chinoise.
Par contre.
Mais bon, c'est bien, je garde
Il a l'air bien aiguisé en plus
C'est lourd, ça vient
Ça vient
Oh le poids !
Mais c'est quand qu'on le voit là ?
Vous avez dit 300 ?
Attention à tes mains quand tu les mets devant Baptiste
Allez
Ca a laché
C'est vraiment lourd, on n'était pas loin de le voir
Pas de trace d'essence
Après la première mobylette, une deuxième, Piaggio
Quasiment au même endroit
Quasiment et il y a autre chose
Elles sont entassés
Alors, qu'est ce qu'on a de beau ici ?
Oui, une pince,
Elle fonctionne toujours, sympa
Oh mince !
Aïe, aïe, aïe aïe aïe aïe.
J'ai un peu raté l'eau, je crois vraiment.
Un landeau, super
Des bijoux
Bien jouer une montre de marque Rodania
Une montre pour femmes.
Ça, ça a été donné par un garage.
Rodania
Une Casio
Normalement les Casio sont étanches
Celle là doit être dans l'eau depuis longtemps
Et toutes ces pièces, du coup.
Donc des francs collector mais pas que
Ça fait des bras.
Ca sent la mobylette.
Mobylette entière, on dirait
Besoin d'aide ?
Oui, peut être pour voir.
Ah ouais ouais c'est gros, attend
Je peux l'attacher aussi.
Alors on a l'aide de Popeye
qui va envoyer le grappin.
On a peur que l'aimant lâche
et quelle retombe
Dommage
Tu as un bout comme ça,
il s'est coupé en deux.
Il y a plein de morceaux ici
L'autre, il est lourd.
Peut être qu'il y a les deux roues
Il y a une corde dessous
Ah ouais, ils sont tenus.
Tant qu'on tire tout
Il y a un scout là bas
avec plus que le cadre.
c'est la roue arrière qui va peser le plus lourd
Mince, le réservoir s'en va
On essaiera de l'attraper après
OK, c'est sympa, nickel.
Il a des roues minuscules.
Si vous savez le modèle, dites le nous en commentaire.
Oh oui, une grosse pile
De la bonne dépollution
Quel enfer de jeter ça dans le canal
Ils n'ont pas honte.
N'importe quoi.
Tout ce qu'il y a, une poignée de vélo
et un morceau de pot d'échappement de mobylette.
Qu'est ce que j'ai de beau ?
Un moteur ?
Encore un moteur de mobylette
Dites nous en commentaire si vous savez à quel modèle appartient ce moteur
Alors, qu'est-ce que tu nous sort là ?
Je peux même pas l'annoncer mais je pense qu'il y aura au moins une barre de fer
Aussi un morceau de scooter, sûrement.
Il y a du poids, ça va être intéressant.
C'est encore plein. Ici.
On va regarder ce qu'on a
C'est des morceaux de cadres
et un peu de tout.
Des morceaux de câbles, de cadre
de la fonte.
Il y a un truc qui a une forme intéressante.
C'est un portable, ça,
c'est une écrevisse.
Ouais, mais du coup, cette fois ci, elle n'est pas de Louisiane.
C'est une Blanche
Donc on peut la relâcher
Elles sont différentes un peu
Coup dur !
Elle a prit cher
Elle était en vie quand elle est tombée.
C'est un portable.
Oui, mais c'est un smartphone, il est tout fin
Il est tout explosé surtout.
Tu vois c'est bien, ils ont gardé la vitre de protection.
Est ce qu'elle a fonctionné ?
Dommage.
Ouais, c'est quand même assez vieux, ok.
Et un couteau.
Tu as vu ?
Tu l'as relâché lui aussi ?
T'as fait comme l'écrevisse, c'est pareil.
Il a fait la même trajectoire.
C'est vraiment bizarre, c'est cool.
Ça va rester campé de ce côté
un peu.
La corde est accrochée sur un gros objet,
donc là on va sortir le treuil,
on va l'installer ici.
On va voir si ce panneau est assez bien ancré dans le sol.
Surement oui, la base à l'air bien costaud,
sinon on le mettra sur l'échelle.
Et l'objectif c'est de remonter l'objet
avec cette corde, le long de la pente.
Est-ce que ca bulle ? Toujours pas
Ca me  paraît illogique que se soit si lourd
Mais ça vient !
Bah oui ça vient
Sinon la corde aurait lâchée.
Bon, allez on est au bout
On va devoir défaire et refaire un autre nœud plus loin.
Alors ça vient ?
Le poids du machin !
On est déjà au bout.
On voit un nuage de terre
Ils ont déjà sorti des tonnes de cadres de moto et cette fois il y en a une qui a l'air entière
Ah oui, là, c'est plus lourd là.
On va s'amuser
Oui, le grappin est bien dedans déjà
C'est normal, c'est moi l'ai lancé
Tu veux une médaille ?
C'est parti !
Je ne suis pas trop bien dessus
Il y a la plaque !
Il y a clairement la plaque les gars
On essaie de le décaler ou de le soulever ?
Il vaut mieux le décaler
Ils amènent la moto au bord
Elle n'a pas l'air si lourde votre moto les gars
C'est original de promener son scooter
Comme un gros poisson tenu en laisse
Attendez, je passe avec ma corde
là bas, en face.
Rasta est venu aux premières loges
pour assister à la sortie du scooter.
On va y arriver.
Ah oui, le plus dur est fait
Ouais c'est un scooter
C'est un garçon
Il n'y a pas la roue avant
Elle ne doit pas être bien loin
Bien joué les gars
Bien joué.
Alors.
Digita
La plaque d'immatriculation Baptiste, regarde
Ouais, bah il n'est pas si vieux.
Elle commence par DB
C'est une plaque récente ( après 2013 )
Ils n'ont pas récupérés tant de pièces que ça
Non, ils l'ont un peu volé pour rien
Ils ont juste dû s'amuser avec
Là dedans, est ce qu'il y a quelque chose ?
Il n'y a rien
Il  y a des gens là dedans
A la recherche de gens
Ca donne envie d'aller voir mais bon
Je ne pense pas qu'ils seraient content
Pendant que Quentin est en train de cuire
sous la chaleur
Je n'en peut plus
On a la septième mobylette
qui est en train d'arriver.
Qu'est ce que tu en penses, Quentin ?
Pendant que nous, on a sorti
pas grand chose là bas.
Là bas c'est mort ...
Un cadre de Peugeot 103
D'un beau bleu avec un sac poubelle magnifique en plus
Aïe, aïe, aïe, aïe, aïe aïe.
Tout doucement
Aïe, aïe ! Aïe !
On est bon là
jouer.
Il y a un autocollant pour dire la bonne.
Ça rappelle ma jeunesse, oui.
Comme si c'était une
première fois.
Ça me tire sans me dire.
Si c'est lourd.
À pour essayer là bas.
Après une demi heure.
C'est super lourd, ça le fait.
Ouais.
Je suis tiré, vous.
Roulez.
Par ci par là et.
Ça viendra.
Jusqu'à voir
ça bien.
Oui, c'est une énorme barrière,
une échelle, une barrière.
Une une cage de prison.
Pour un délai très long.
Un rapprochement pour t'aider. Hein ?
Vous pouvez pas tirer ?
Ben non
mais de là bas on se décompose, non ?
Un, deux, trois
ou trois
un deux trois
deux de pas.
On est presque allé
voir de. Six
à putain.
On pose en poste.
On pose.
C'est un château fort, beau.
Il va tomber bientôt pour lui.
On y est presque là. Il y a une chaise.
Il y a tellement de trucs
ça. Tu vois, tu vas y arriver en continu.
On y arrive un, deux.
Trois.
Allez deux fois
un peu de toi.
Alors là, c'est trop dur. T'as
pas de quoi
ou de quoi
à une table
à trois
deux trois pour voir.
On y est presque.
Oui, il y a une moto au bout. Il y a.
Une. Photocopieuse.
C'est n'importe quoi.
Alors allons y presque.
Tu m'étonnes que tout. Autour de la terre.
Là, un barrage de 300 kilos, voilà.
Deux trois.
Faut monter dessus,
aller chercher la mobylette ou. Ça.
Marche pas.
Déjà ça l'a déjà un peu récupéré.
Safari
trois.
Gérard.
Une partie.
Oh là ça.
Moins dans un château, ça aussi.
Le poids de ça par rapport. À la grille,
c'est négligeable.
Ouais, mais quand même, on va tirer,
on va dire.
C'est la mode. Oui.
Quand même.
C'est bien payé.
Je comprends
pourquoi ont galéré comme moi.
Mais rien que la forme machin de taille.
Si vous voulez faire une prison
sans se faire
condamner carrément.
Ouais, clairement
on continue.
Pour finir, ceux qui font des esclaves
game prison et tout là.
Par la grille.
On fini.
Je finis seul, non seul avec
ce qui est chance de sous,
tu peux pas l'enlever non. Pas.
Une nouvelle mobylette,
la huitième à la huitième,
mais là, l'utilitaire, il va déborder.
Aujourd'hui, il y avait. Un vrai gang
de voleurs de mobylette.
Si c'est vous, dénoncez vous,
il y a prescription.
Belle trouvaille. Car.
Ça serait un virus libéral.
Oui, oui, oui,
oui. Oui. On a sorti.
Les chiens, les chiens aussi.
On en a acheté.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Rien à voir il y a un mois pour le sortir.
Maintenant qu'elle est tombée.
Non mais sérieusement, peut être.
On en a. Pas.
Avant
de poser n'importe quoi, il fait 30 ans
qu'on essaie de la sortir.
Pour les chiens, yankee dad.
Allez hop hop Jade vous !
Un retour aux Experts basiques ?
C'est quand même plus pratique.
Avec l'utilitaire Free.
Récemment.
Bon, allez.
Un de plus, mais quand même.
Du coup, on a dit une dizaine
sur la.
Vous êtes beaucoup à nous demander
ce que l'on fait de toute la ferraille
que l'on ramasse.
Même si certains d'entre vous
le savent déjà,
on accumule toute la ferraille
dans un garage
et on la voit au poids chez un ferrailleur
lorsque c'est nécessaire.
Et aujourd'hui, on a donc décidé de vous
emmener avec nous chez le ferrailleur.
On va voir combien de kilos de ferraille
on arrive à vendre,
mais surtout combien on va en tirer.
Dans un premier temps,
c'est la tâche la plus fastidieuse.
Il faut remplir le camion.
Heureusement, cette fois ci,
on a un camion plateau
et on a été aidé par notre ami Marc.
Encore un grand merci pour ton aide.
C'est
impressionnant de se dire
que tout ça a été dans l'eau.
Vous pouvez voir la quantité de cadre
de scooter
incroyable. Qu'est ce penses Marc ?
J'ai essayé les autres.
Et il en reste.
Il en reste.
On va continuer à charger.
Je pense pas qu'on ait le temps
de tout faire sur cette aller là.
Vu la taille du temps encore.
Mais bon, c'est déjà un bon début,
c'est déjà pas mal.
Allez, on continue.
Le fameux qui claque
et le camion qui se remplit pas mal.
On commence à être bien là.
Ils sont là pour.
Regarder la quantité.
Voilà pour le chargement.
Je me demande combien on pourra.
On va voir ça rapidement.
Il en reste un peu dans le garage,
mais c'est déjà très bien.
Regardez moi
ce camion qu'on a rempli vers l'assemblée.
C'est pas top,
mais ça va la faire ferraille ça. Vous
va ? Et cette fois ci,
on va essayer de ne pas prendre d'amende
puisque c'est vrai
que ça, c'était un petit peu mal passé.
Là, avoir payé 90€.
D'amende
pour avoir fait tomber dans le rond.
Point pour un excès de vitesse.
Là, c'est le test du rond point.
Arrivera doucement et là dessus.
Il est sérieux.
Bon, tu parles sur combien là ?
Dans lequel ?
En tout, autour.
Du coup, moi je dirais.
Donne 500.
Ouais.
200€ et 200€.
On espère.
Ça, c'est de la grue en Bretagne,
il y a de la.
On y va.
Il va donc.
Falloir
encore de la merde.
Quasi. C'est un mirage.
Du vainqueur
du futur.
La Google, c'est là.
Là, on atteint son.
Rêve du inconnu.
Qui continue.
À donner la parole à.
La classe. En
face de la page.
Mais avec.
Ce lézard.
Jamais
majuscule, toujours.
Au sommaire.
Là bas, il ne reste.
Dans ce cinéma.
C'est certainement qu'il nous faut la
silhouette.
1550, 150 kilos en avant une mise en scène
15€.
Ouais, c'est bien ce qu'on avait dit.
Et un camion qui attend lequel on sort
pour ce média.
Genoux pour
tromper la.
Aucune info.
Merci.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plus
mais nous on reviendra.
Laurent Delahousse Et vous, il n'est pas
senti votre coffre fort si vous.
Pensez. Encore, c'est passionnant.
Dites nous en commentaire.
Si vous voulez une partie trois.
En tout cas,
un grand merci à ces empêcheurs de trésors
de leur réseau sans description.
Ils sont en live sur Tweeter
tous les dimanches.
Si je me trompe pas,
quasiment tous les dimanches.
On n'aurait pas pu jour.
Là, c'était impossible
à quatre, c'était très compliqué d'en
parler.
La semaine prochaine,
pour une nouvelle vidéo de pêche à.